when the whistle blows hopes rise
[Applause]
there are at least 21 000 rescue
Personnel still looking and listening
for signs of life among the ruins of The
Villages towns and cities of hatai in
Southeastern turkey
survivors are desperate for something to
show that a loved one may still be alive
where buildings are pancaked in seconds
there's a chance someone has been tossed
into a gap medanie demur has been a
rescuer for seven years and owns a
construction company
we need to take advantage of the first
72 hours to rescue people alive
unfortunately people don't know what to
do when earthquakes happen they don't
know what to look for in a house before
they purchase one is it durable how is
it built if you buy 30 to 40 year old
houses with renovated facades this is
what is going to happen to them
iskandarin's Port is on fire swathes of
the city are without electricity running
water and sanitation
four days after the Quakes hit this city
tens of thousands are now homeless my
cousin and my brother-in-law are in here
we've been waiting for three days today
they rescued a girl and her mother
yesterday they found the bodies of three
people our pain is great I can't express
it enough they'll sleep tonight in one
of the thousands of tents the Turkish
government has shipped in
the biggest challenge for us is the
relatives of the victims we need to tell
them what we're doing while we're
carrying out the rescue operation they
want to interfere and do things we're
unable to control the rescue area
The Rescuers know that time is now
running out to find any more survivors
there is so much death here and on a
scale I think people still find
incomprehensible that people really
cling to any hope there is even this
long after the initial earthquake and
that is why here again they're hoping
for a minor miracle but there wasn't
there are perhaps thousands of times
when Rescuers hopes rise only to be
dashed again but the search for
survivors hasn't been called off yet
when there is still parts of this
country waiting for the first rescue
teams to arrive Bernard Smith Al Jazeera
iskandarin